Ukrainian officials say three people
have died in Russian drone strikes in
the Kiev region military sources say a
civilian object was damaged and the
attack and rescue workers are still at
the scene Stephanie deck is joining me
now from Kiev what's the latest on this
drone attack
yes it appears to be two residential
buildings in an area southeast of the
capital as you mentioned there from what
we understand from Rescue workers three
dead two injured one person was pulled
from the rubble it's the first time in
months that a civilian building has been
struck in the area surrounding or inside
the capital the Ukrainian military is
saying that 16 out of 21 drones uh
Iranian made drones launched by Russia
overnight were shot down we heard
airstrike air raid sirens in the evening
across the country as well we've just
had a statement from the Ukrainian
President Vladimir zielinski calling
these you know yet another a barrage of
murderous drones launched at Ukraine as
the Russian president talks peace
referring to a brief statement that he
referred to Ukraine and Xi Jinping the
Chinese president's visit there he has
now left by the way the Chinese
president has left Moscow but saying at
the same time they launched these kinds
of attack I think it is important to
remember also keep relatively speaking
very much away from the front line yes
you do hear Airaid Sirens go off you're
almost on a daily basis but it is a
reminder but then all of a sudden yes
Strife can happen again because people
here really do no longer respond to
those Air Raid Sirens but I think a
reminder again these drone strikes
overnight that this Still Remains a very
active war zone that's just the focus to
Crimea Russia is saying it's Navy's
repelled a drone attack there what more
do we know about that
yes the moscow-backed governor of
Sebastopol
um in Crimea saying that it repelled
shot down three drones that were
entering an area where the Black Sea
Fleet is based
um of course alleging that these are
Ukrainian drones there have been
multiple strikes on Russian facilities
in Crimea over the course of this war
never claimed by the ukrainians it
follows on Monday we also had reports
the Ukrainian military saying that
various Russian cruise missiles were
destroyed in an attack it appear to be
the transportation of these cruise
missiles in a train station again no
confirmation but this is um as to who
was behind it but this is something that
happened Monday video emerged you could
see nighttime pictures of burning
um so this again in the last three days
gives you a sense of again Ukraine never
confirms these kinds of attacks but that
it does
try to at least you know Crimea was
annexed in 2014 it's home to the Russian
Black Sea Fleet that Fleet uses these
cruise missiles that have a capacity
over a thousands of kilometer range on
land to fire from the sea at Targets in
Ukraine
Stephanie thank you very much indeed
Stephanie Decker bringing us up to date
from Keith